euh, c'était un jour de 4 heures où il a
pu quitter l'
hôpital [Musique], il était super heureux, aimait s'amuser, euh,
extraverti mais seulement avec les gens que vous connaissez avec
qui il serait passionné, il
m'a appelé pendant que j'étais chez mon ami
et  a dit
qu'il avait des pensées suicidaires et qu'il
ne savait pas quoi
faire alors j'ai appelé
et elle a juste
dit qu'il l'avait fait cette fois, il avait réussi
et Ashton est
parti
[Musique]
Police régionale avec deux chefs d'accusation de
conseil et d'aide au suicide
en 15 ans environ  mais il y a en fait
certaines de mes photos préférées de lui, il
n'était pas quelqu'un qui aimait se faire
prendre en photo, donc nous n'en
avons pas beaucoup. Je ne dis pas que les
problèmes de Tom auraient été résolus
facilement, il l'était.  il se débattait, il était
déprimé mais je sais que si ce
forum sur le suicide n'existait pas, il serait toujours avec nous
aujourd'hui et je suis sûr qu'il se rétablirait
littéralement. Il y avait des gens en ligne qui
l'encourageaient à se
suicider.  je lui ai également fourni un
kit de suicide pour se suicider si naïvement à
l'époque pendant que Tom me parlait, j'avais
presque l'impression que je ne l'avais pas vraiment vu
faire ça, je ne l'ai pas vu,
c'est vraiment difficile à savoir
que le di de mon fils, il
y a un lien clair avec la
loi euh, il savait ce qu'il faisait quand il
a envoyé un kit de suicide à mon fils, à mon avis, il
savait clairement que Tom allait utiliser
ça pour se suicider
et pourtant il me semble qu'il le
fera  ne jamais être accusé de la mort de mon fils
Police régionale avec deux chefs d'accusation de
counseling